the key for a man is self-control for
women it's authenticity you have to say
authentic as possible because our body
tells us so much our body will tell you
when you're craving a child when you're
getting angry because our hormones are
all over the place for a man your body
sometimes speaks against you it will
crave pleasure your key to successful
mental health is complete and utter
self-control in terms of your mind body
and soul you control what you consume
you control who you put yourself into
you don't go and sleep with every single
one you actually gain far more
self-esteem when you reject women than
when you accept women that man that has
women that he's rejecting feels far
greater than that man who can't say no
to anybody because he's jumping at the
opportunities self-control even with
what you eat when I have clients that
come to me and they've got a bit of
depression I say to them until you go to
the gym until you lose weight there's no
conversation that me and you can have
that will change your self-esteem it
won't do it don't have to have a
six-pack but self-control now when a man
practices self-control he becomes such
an unshakable being